benim Z mcik 9 sınıf öğrenim CF kar
okuluna YouTube'un en büyük craf
kanalına Hepiniz hoş geldiniz Z takımı
Paraf okula destek kampımız bugün geldik
ikinci videosuna ilk videoda coğrafyanın
konusunu öğrenmiştik Bu videoda
coğrafyanın bölümlerini öğreneceğiz bu
video senin için çok çok önemli çünkü
bölümlerde bir sürü kavram var o
kavramları karıştırabilirsiniz
yer burası Ama merak etmeyin hafıza
teknikleriyle kodlamalarla beraber Ne
diyorduk bir defa öğreneceğiz bir daha
asla unutmayacağız Sen hazırsan abone
olarak e abone olmadan izlemiyorsunuz
herhalde 4 yıl boyunca beraberiz abone
olmadan izlemek olur mu abone olacaksın
abone olup kemik Kadrodan olacaksın 4
yıl sonra kemik kadro olacaksın hain
kostok olmayacaksın abone olmadan
izleyerek Abone oldun kemik kadro
olduğuna göre o zaman ne diyoruz Yunus
hocayla bir defa öğren bir daha asla
unutma gelin şu derse para fatal geldik
ikinci güne şimdi coğrafyanın
bölümlerine bakacağız bugün ama bir şey
değişti ne demiştim size videolara konu
anlatımına başlarken pdf'leri ücretsiz
alabiliyorsunuz demiştik hala
alabiliyorsunuz hem de renkli bir
şekilde zeda ncom danan bütün branşları
fizik kimya biyoloji hepsini yüklüyoruz
oraya alabilirsiniz bunları kitap olarak
bastırmayı düşünmüyoruz demiştik zaten
istediğiniz gibi çıktı alabiliyorsunuz
Ama orada çok Yorum geldi hocam soru
bankası çözmeyecek mi diye bizim soru
bankamız yok Ara sınıflarda ama Paraf
yayınlarına bu durumu ilettik Paraf
Yayınları da hocam dedi sorun değil
bizim soru bankalarımız çıktı 9 sınıfta
Yeni müfredata uygun et etkinliklerin
yazılıların olduğu bütün soru
bankalarımız çıktı bunları alıp
öğrencileriniz de kullanabilirsiniz sağ
olsun ücretsiz bir şekilde verdi Biz de
şimdi artık sadece konu anlatımı değil
konu anlatımından hemen sonra soru
çözümleri de yapacağız sadece soru
çözümleri de değil Hemen şöyle açayım
size sayfayı evet bize verdikleri kitap
bu Müfredata uygun yeni çıkmış Bunda
sadece soru bankası değil bu soru
bankası etkinlikler alıştırma testleri
yazılı örnekleri her şey var Bu kitabı
bütün sene boyunca Bu kampta çözeceğiz
nasıl çöz çözeceğim ii göstereyim size
bir konu bitti diyelim mesela bugün
coğrafyanın bölümleri konusu bitecek ya
hemen peşinde ne çözeceğiz biliyor
musunuz şöyle testler var testleri çözüp
pekiştirecek bütün konulardan sonra
böyle testleri çözüp
pekiştirecek gençler ünite bittiğinde ne
yapacağız biliyor musunuz ünite ölçme
testleri var bakın ve bazen orada
alıştırmalar kısmı da oluyor ünite ölçme
testlerini ve boşluk doldurmalı şeklinde
alıştırmaların olduğu kısımlar da var o
alıştırmaları ünite genel tekrarı olarak
size hemen video yapacağım ne yaptık bir
bölümü işledik ikinci bölümü işledik
testini çözdük Bütün bunların ünite
bitti üniteden sonra hemen ünite ölçme
testleri ile beraber bütün gerideki
kısımları tekrar ettik Mi ettik Sonra
bakın Bu kitapta bir de sınav performans
testi var Sınav performans testini ve
hemen ondan sonra etkinlik açık uçlu
sorular kısmını yazılıdan önce çözeceğiz
yazılıdan önce geleceğim size Şuradaki
kısmı sınav performans testi etkinlik
açık uçlu sorular var Bakın aynı
yazılıdan size yazılıya hazırlık genel
tekrar diye bir video yapacağım bunları
da orada çözeceğiz tamam mı yazılı
hazırlık genel tekrar da yapacağız yani
ne yaptık konu işledik konunun
testlerini pekiştirmek için çözdük sonra
ünite bitti üniteyi genel tekrar ettik
bu kitaptan sonra yazılı geldi yazılı
genel tekrarlarını bunlardan yaptık açık
uçlu sorulardan yaptık Sonra yazılı
geldi yazılıda da yine bakın yazılı
sınav soruları var burada iki tane
yazılımımız var İki tane yazılımımız
örneğini de buradan çözdük yetti mi
Yetmedi bir de beşinci yi yapacağız
tekrar testi var burada yazılıya iki
tane örnekle hazırlandık bu tekrar
testlerini de 3üncü yazılı örneği olarak
çözeceğiz ama test soruları şeklinde
yazılıya hazırlayacağım size yani ü tane
de yazılıya hazırlık videomuz olacak
buradan bütün bu kitabı bu sene böyle
takip edeceğiz testimizi çözeceğiz genel
tekrarımız yapacağız yazılıyı
hazırlayacağız Bu kitap bizim bu şekilde
takip edeceğimiz bir kitap buradan
paragraf yayınlarına Ben açıkçası ve
zümrelere zümre hocalarıma kendi adıma
teşekkür ediyorum bu imkanı bize sunduğu
için şimdi gelelim bugünkü konumuza
şimdi coğrafyanın bölümleri şöyle gözünü
dört aç Beni dinle Çünkü yazılıda
buradan soru geliyor gençler Çünkü
burada yabancı kavramlar var Bunu
karıştırdığınız biliyorlar
yapamayacağınızı düşünüyorlar ve
Haklılar da ama sizin hafıza teknikleri
ve kodlamaları yaptığınızı bilmiyorlar
bu konu zor gibi görünür ama asıl beleş
bütün puanları buradan kapacak sınız
coğrafyayı Ben ayıracak olsam bak
ezberleme coğrafyayı şimdi ayıracağım
Bir önceki derse ne görmüştük seninle
hocam coğrafya vardı bir insan vardı
Beşer diyorduk ona Beşir diyorduk bir
insan vardı bir de dışarıda Doğa var ya
bu doğayla bu insanın etkileşimini ve
ilişkilerini inceliyordu değil mi
coğrafya E o zaman coğrafyanın tanımı
buysa coğrafyanın tanımını yapmayı öğren
Çünkü çıkar karşına coğrafyanın tanımını
yazınız der Ne yapacaksın Eee insan var
Doğa var doğa ve insanın karşılıklı
ilişkisi ve etkileşimini inceleyen bilim
dalıdır dedin mi bakın coğrafyanın
bölümlerini de aslında ortaya
çıkarttınız nasıl E şimdi Doğa dedim
insan dedim E o zaman ben coğrafyayı
ikiye ayıracağım hocam bir insanın
içerisinde olduğu insana ne diyorduk
beşeri coğrafya diyorduk Evet cevabı
duydum beşeri coğrafya diyeceğim insanın
içinde olmadığı dışarıda Doğa var Ona da
doğal coğrafya diyeceğim ama doğal
coğrafya olmuyor gibi dışarıdaki o doğal
çevre fiziki çevre değil mi o fiziki
çevre işte ona fiziki coğrafya diyeceğim
doğal coğrafya değil de fiziki coğrafya
diyeceğim Demek ki coğrafyayı kaça
ayırdım ikiye ayırdım doğal doğal
değildi Pardon fiziki coğrafya beşeri
coğrafya fiziki coğrafya Neyi
inceleyecek dışarıdaki doğal koşulları
inceleyecek değil mi bakın Ne var burada
Doğal çevrede meydana gelen ve insanları
etkileyen doğal olayları inceleyecek bu
Bunlar ne Klimatoloji Jeomorfoloji hidro
hidrografya biyocoğrafya ve toprak
coğrafyası Hocam ben şimdi bunları
ezberleyecek miyim ezberleme gerek yok
ne yapacağız hafıza teknikleriyle
hepsini şimdi sana göstereceğim ne
birincisi fiziki çevrede Jeomorfoloji ne
demek hocam benimle beraber tekrar
ediyorsun şimdi bak kesin tekrar etmen
lazım etmezsen aklında kalmaz Ama
edersen bir daha unutamayacaksın jeo yer
jeo yer benimle beraber tekrar et etmez
sen olmaz jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo
yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo
yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer
tekrar etmezsen olmaz beyninin içinde
yankılansın bir defa öğren bundan 4 sene
sonra üniversite sınavına girecekken
bile şına joo çıktığında yerde ama şimdi
bu tekniği kullan ben bunları
ezberlesin Unutursun sadece bir ders yok
ki 50 tane ders var jeo jeo yer jeo yer
jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer
test sorusu çözerken anlayacaksın niye
böyle dediğimi jeo yer jeoloji desem
sana jeo yer loji bilimi zaten jeoloji
yer bilimi Peki hocam Jeomorfoloji ne
bak jeo jeo yer yer hocam morfo morfo
hemen böyle not al jeo yer morfo motife
benzemiyor mu bak morfo motif morfo
modifiye modifiye de benziyor modifiye
de ne yapıyoruz arabaya şekil yapıyoruz
morfo motif motif şekil yapmak değil mi
morfo şekil bak şekil çok güzel bir
yazım var değil mi Jeomorfoloji yer
şekilli bilme yer şekillerini inceliyor
musu Demek ki coğrafyanın
bölümlerinden Jeomorfoloji yer
şekillerini inceleyecek bakın dağ
oluşumları volkanizma tektonik olaylar
dağlar platolar ovalar vadiler Bunların
hepsi nerede yer şekilleriyle alakalı
değil mi jeomorfolojinin konusu o zaman
anlaştık mı bunan sorsak sana aşağıdan
hangisi ya da yukarıda dağlar ovalar
platolar falan diyecek yukarıda
verilenler hangisi coğrafyanın
aşağıdakilerden hangisinin inceleme
alanına girer dağ ova yer şekli hocam
bunlar Jeomorfoloji diyeceksin bu ne
coğrafyanın bölümü değil mi coğrafyanın
bir bölümü Peki hocam şurada bir kısım
var bunun jeomorfolojinin yararlandığı
bazı bilimler var Bunlar da bizim
karşımıza çıkıyor ve bizim kafamızı çok
karıştırıyor asıl Bunlar karıştırıyor
kafamızı Neden şöyle hafif bir küçülte
oraya resim atacağım Çünkü şöyle bakın
Bunlar ayrı bir bilim jeoloji ayrı bir
bilim jeoloji yer bilimi bu ayrı Bu
coğrafyanın bilimi değil tamam mı
jeoloji ayrı bir bilim coğrafyanın
bölümü jeomorfolojiye mi bu Coğrafyayla
alakalı ama bu
jeomorfolojiye erini incelerken Şimdi
biz coğrafyacılar olarak gidip de bütün
bilimlerin yaptığı şeyleri yapamayız
bakın kimya Kimyayı yapamayız Jeofizik
jeoloji bunları yapamayız Bunlar ayrı
bir bilim Ama bu bilimlerden
yararlanırız biz işte bunlardan
yararlandığımız da bunlar bizim
yararlandığımız bilimler oluyor yani
Jeomorfoloji hangilerinden
yararlanabilir diye bir soru çıkabiliyor
karşımıza şimdi Jeomorfoloji yer
şekilleri Ben şimdi yer şekillerini
yaparken bakarken jeolojiden
yararlanırım mantıken aynı şey zaten
Jeomorfoloji yer şekli bilimi jeoloji
yer bilimi tamam bundan yararlandım
jeolojiye gerek yok zaten kod adık
jeoloji yer bilimi Jeofizik yer fiziği
bundan da yararlanırız e Kimyadan da
yararlanıyoruz orada yer şekillerini
incelerken bir sürü ihtiyacımız oluyor
kimyasal olarak bu da tamam buraya kadar
Tamam mıyız Bunlar kolaydı Ama şuna
bakın pedr grafi deli Pedro ne demek
hocam deli Pedro petrografi deli Pedro
Siz Rus Çarı deli Pedro biliyor musunuz
Nasıl hocam Rus Çarı deli Pedro yu
bilmiyor musunuz deli Pedro var orada
çok ünlü niye delirmiş O adam biliyor
musunuz çocukken Şuraya bak şuraya
şuraya bakıyorsun çocukken kafasına taş
yemiş kafasına taş yiyince de bu adam
delirmiş O yüzden de buna deli Pedro
demişler deli Pedro Pedro deli Pedro
niye delirdi kafasına taş yediği için
kayaç bilimi taş bilimi bazı kaynaklarda
bu karşımıza litoloji olarak da
çıkabilir aynı şey kayaç taş litoloji
bakın burada ne var Litosfer var litos
taştan geliyordu taş bilimi diyeceksin
tamam Tamam bunları öğrendik mi
geçiyorum jeomorfolojiye öğrendik şöyle
bir soru çözelim hemen bunu çözemiyoruz
gençler ÖSYM sorusu ÖSYM bu tarz
soruların çözümünü bizim yapmamıza izin
vermiyor çözersek telif yerim beni
mahvederler ama sen şimdi kendin bunu
çözüyorsun Anlaştık mı Ben çözümünü
yapamıyorum geçiyorum şimdi bundan
geldik buraya ik Klimatoloji ik
Klimatoloji mi Pardon yanlış mı okudum
ya bir dakika biraz Yakınlaştır iklim
atoi Pardon yanlış mı görüyorum ya
burada i harfi mi eksik yanlış yazmışlar
bunu herhalde yanlış yazmamışlar
Klimatoloji
Klimatoloji diyeceksin Sen buna yazarken
çizerken Hep oraya bir i harfi koy klima
iklima iklim Gençler bu Klima var orada
zaten klima iklimimiz değiştirmiyor mu
bizim yani odadaki iklimimiz Evet bu ne
iklima diyeceksin iklimle alakalı
şeyleri olayları inceleyen coğrafyanın
alt dalı iklim bilimi Klimatoloji E neyi
inceleyecek o zaman bakın sıcaklık
basınç nem yağış Bunların hepsi
iklimlerle alakalı değil mi yağış
iklimle alakalı basınç sıcaklık iklimle
alakalı o zaman klimatolojinin inceleme
alanında Tamam merak etmeyin test
çözeceğiz bu videodan sonra test
çözümleri gelecek o videoyu dikkatli
dinleyeceksin pekiştireceksiniz
iklimlerin yeryüzüne dağılışı bakın Hah
hocam Klimatoloji Peki herhangi bir
bilimden yararlanıyor mu evet neyden
meteorolojiden meteorolojiyi
duymuşsundur Haberlerde ne diyor
meteorolojiden alınan bilgilere göre
Yarın hava yağışlı olacak meteorolojiden
alınan bilgilere göre kar yağışı
bekleniyor meteoroloji gençler hava
durumunu Hava olaylarını ifade ediyor
meteoroloji biraz daha kısa süreli hava
olayları klima iklim daha uzun süreli
Demek ki Klimatoloji Pardon Klimatoloji
neyden yararlanacak meteorolojiden
geçtim
hidrografya Hocam ben artık hidro
öğrendim neydi H2 H2O hidro hidrojen su
H2O hocam suları inceleyen kısma da
hidrografya sular coğraf coğrafyası
diyeceğiz Peki geldik buraya hocam
inceleme alanında ne olacak E su
hidrografya su Okyanus Deniz Göl Akarsu
Bunlar olacak Okyanus Göl su Bunların
hepsi su Tamam peki yararlandığı bilim
geldik burada biraz bayağı bir
öğreneceğimiz şey var çıkıyor karşımıza
hidroloji Hocam bu basit hocam buraya
H2O yu koydum hidroloji hidro H2O su
loji bilim su bilme Tamam koydum bak
Burada ne diyor potamoloji bunun şimdi
Akarsu bilmi olduğunu öğrenmen lazım
Nasıl Bizim seninle balık tutmamız lazım
potalar var Bak şimdi potalar nasıl olur
altında ağ olur değil mi Böylece o
potayı alsak akarsuya götürsek akarsuda
şöyle güzelce bir balık tutsak çok güzel
olmaz mı be ha çok güzel olur değil mi
potamoloji Bak aslında kodlamaları
ezberlemiş Biz burada hafıza
tekniklerine bazen gelecek şarkı
söyleyeceğiz Bazen tekrar yapacağız yeo
yer jeo yer jeo yer gibi ama bunları
ezberlememiz gerek kalmıyor niye biliyor
musunuz şıktır test çözüyoruz karşımıza
çıktı potamoloji pota aa Hocam şu resim
pota potada balık tutuyorduk akarsuda o
potaya balık tutuyorduk Tamam Akarsu
dedin Bak bu kadar bu kadar kodladım mı
limnoloji Ben şimdi şöyle Nasrettin
hocayım tamam mı Şu tarafta mı Ha şöyle
Nasrettin hocayım gidiyorum gölün
kenarındayım Göle limon sıkıyorum Göle
gitmişim limon sıkıyorum bak ne
sıkıyorum Göle limon sıkıyorum bütün
göldeki suyu ekşi hale getireceğim Çünkü
ekşi Su içmek istiyorum ben Siz de bana
diyorsunuz ki
ya Hocam hocam Ne yapıyorsun Göle limon
sıkılır mı ya Göle limon sıkıp Gölü
ekşit demezsin ki ben de diyorum ki ya
ekşirse ya ekşirse Yani ne yaptım bak
limnoloji limon limon geldi aklıma Aa ne
yapmıştı Yunus hoca hepimizi hepinizi
topladım gölün kenarına gittim Gölü
ekşitmeyen limon Göl bilimi diyeceksin
Bir defa öğreneceksin 4 sene geçecek 4
sene sonra üniversite sınavına girmeye
gittiğinde bile limnoloji denildiğinde
unutmayacaksın O yüzden Yunus hocayla
bir defa öğren bir daha asla unutma
diyoruz Hatta sınava bile çalışırken
yeniden coğrafya çalışmana gerek
kalmayacak yazılan önce öyle bir tekrar
ederek gireceksin bir bakacaksın sınavda
hepsi aklına gelecek limnoloji Anladık
mı Göl e Göl o zaman hidrografyanın
altında
hidrojeoloji bakın bir kere kodladım mı
Nasıl işine yarıyor hidro jeoloji hidro
H2O jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer su H2O su
yer bilim Yerin altındaki suları
inceliyor Bak bu kadar kolay işte bir
defa temelini düzgü at her şey geliyor
diğeri hocam e Hepsini mi kodlayaz hocam
hepsini kodlayaz sana bir tane bile
kavram bırakmayacağım bu kanalın ismi ne
coğrafyanın kodları bir tane bile
kodlanmamış şey kalmayacak hiç merak
etme en zor kavramları bile yüzlerce
kavramın hepsini
kodladığı
unutmayacak
oseonografya okuyan
bilmi
oseonografya okyanus bilmi
oseonografya okyanus bilmi diyeceksin
zaten orada Ocean var aslında
İngilizcesi olanlar Ocean Okyanusu
çıkartabilir ama olmayanlar için
oseonografya okyanus bilmi joo Evet jeo
yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo
yer H2O su limnoloji limon sıktık Göle
Göl bilimi Bunlar asıl zor olanlardır
Tamam geldik Toprak coğrafyasına
geçmişteki ayrımlı coğrafyaya ayırırken
Toprak coğrafyasını buraya koymuyor
lardı buraya kartografya koyuyorlardı
ben şimdi sana kartografyaya da
göstereyim ki testlerde karşına çıkınca
bilesin kartografya not almanı istiyorum
Oraya Çünkü karşımıza çıkma ihtimali var
Ayrıca harita bilimini öğrenirken
öğreneceğimiz için şimdi de öğreteyim
sana kartografya kartografya bak yaz
oraya kartografya yaz kartografya karton
bak karton sana bir ödev veriyorum Şimdi
ne dedim sana videoların başında ilk
giriş videosunda ve konu anlatımında
dedim ki bak şimdi coğrafyada başarılı
olmak istiyorsan dünya haritalarını
bileceksin dünya haritalarının temelini
atmazsan coğrafyada başarılı olamazsın
harita bileceksin dedim değil mi o
yüzden sen de gittin ilk önce dünya
haritaları kampını izledin öyle 9 sınıfa
geçtin temel attın ama sana diyorum ki
şimdi tamam haritaları öğrendin ama bir
de harita çizip gelmeni istiyorum senden
harita Çizeceksin o haritaları da
sınıflara asacağız Biz Ama şöyle bir
sıkıntı var senin o çizdiğin haritayı
sınıfa kağıda çizersen asarsa olmaz neye
çizmen lazım kartona Çizeceksin tamam mı
kartona sana ne ödevi verdim harita
çizme ödevi verdim kartografya dediğinde
biri sana kartografya hocam karton
kartonu Ne yapmıştın harita çizmiştim
harita bilimi Gelecek aklına yaz hemen
oraya hemen şöyle kartografya harita
bilmi geçmişte kartografyaya bu fiziki
coğrafyanın alt dallarında anlatıyordu
Ama bu yeni müfredatta onu koymadılar
getirdiler Toprak coğrafyasını koydular
Toprak coğrafyası toprakların oluşumunu
ve özelliklerini dünyada da ve
Türkiye'de dağılışlarını inceliyor
burada zor olan kısım zaten bunu sen
anlarsın Toprak coğrafyası Türkçe
Pedoloji Pedoloji pedol pedal bak
Pedoloji pedal pedala benziyor ya şu
pedala bakar mısın ya her zaman çamurlu
olur değil mi hep böyle Gelir oraya bir
toprak bulaşır suyla da birleşince çamur
olur hep böyle Çamur Olur değil mi
Pedoloji dediğinde sana birisi pedal
Gelecek aklına pedallar hep nasılı bak
gözün önüne Getir görsel öğreniyoruz
Burada pedallar hep Topraklı çamurlu
değil mi Pedoloji pedal Toprak
diyeceksin sana testte Toprak coğrafyası
diye sormaz o basit Pedoloji diye
çıkacak karşına bu senin tamam Pedoloji
toprakmışım adı üstünde mineroloji
mineral o onu çağrıştırıyor E zaten
Topraklar minerallerden oluşuyor gençler
Kayalar var kayaları kırıyorsunuz
kayalarda da mineraller var kayaları
kırıyorsunuz toprağa dönüşüyor
topraklarda da mineral olmuş oluyor
mineral toprağı zaten çağrıştırıyor bunu
da öğrendik mi g gelim fiziki coğrafyayı
bak Bunların hepsi Toprak doğad dı
fiziki coğrafya hidro su dışarıda doğad
dı fiziki coğrafya biyocoğrafya biyo
biyoloji bitki canlıları ifade ediyor E
bu basit E bunun yani bitki ve hayvan
topluluklarının dağılışını inceleyeceği
anlıyorsundur bu basit yararlandığı
bilimlere bakalım E Bunlar da
biyolojiden yararlanacak Ben mesela
biosem Semi hocamdan biosem kanalını
izliyorsunuz herhalde Z takımında
biyoloji kısmını anlatıyor biosem
biyoloji Semi hocamdan hep
yararlanıyorum coğrafya için söylüyorum
biyocoğrafya Öğreneceğim zaman bak
biyoloji Tamam biyolojiden yarar e
Botanik botaniği de biliyoruz bitkileri
ifade ediyor ondan da yararlanacak e zu
hayvanat bahçesi hayvanlar bundan
yararlanıyor şimdiye kadar ne öğrendik
şimdiye kadar fiziki coğrafyayı öğrendik
değil mi fiziki coğrafya dışarıdaki
doğayı Şimdi geldik bakın ikinci bir
ayrım nasıl beşeri coğrafya şeklinde bu
sefer doğayı öğrendik şimdi insan olan
kısımlara geçeceğiz Beşer beşire
benziyordu Beşir bir insandı o zaman
insan coğrafyası kısmına geleceğiz bakın
insanların yeryüzündeki dağılışını
dağılış rol oynayan faktörleri
yaptıkları ekonomik faaliyetleri yani
insanın etkileşimi ile alakalı ne varsa
onları inceliyor geldik ilk olarak bu
beşeri coğrafyanın alt dallarından bir
tanesi nüfus coğrafyası Gençler biz
nüfus coğrafyasını da öğreneceğiz Bu
arada 9 sınıfın ikinci dönem konularında
nüfus coğrafyası da var mesela o konuda
ne öğreneceğiz nüfusun özelliklerine
bakacağız sizinle değişimini dağılışını
hareketlerini göçleri yani nüfus
politikalarını bütün bunları öğreneceğiz
sizinle İkinci dönemde mesela alacağız
Türkiye'nin nüfusuna bakacağız dünyada
nüfusun dağılışına bakacağız bütün
hepsine bakacağız işte o konu nüfus
coğrafyası konusu olacak Burada bir
yabancı kavram var bu çok önemli bizim
için Peki hocam nüfus coğrafyası neyden
yararlanacak demografi hemen demografiye
yaz oraya demografi nüfus bilme Tamam
yaz oraya demografi nüfus bilme
demografi diye bir bilim var zaten o
işleri yapıyor Biz ondan bilgileri alıp
yararlanıyoruz demografi dediğinde
aklına nüfus gelmeli bak burası çok
önemli nasıl gelecek demografi demokrasi
Demokrasiyi kim yapıyor insanlar yapıyor
nüfus yapıyor Değil mi nüfus demokrasi
demografi nüfusu çağrıştıracak bize
Pedoloji pedol pedal pedalda Toprak var
limnoloji limon limonu Göle sıkıyordu
hocam potamoloji akarsuda potla balık
tutuyorduk Akarsu
oseonografya Okyanus Pedro deli Pedro
deli Pedro kafasına taşıyordu dem cfi
demokrasi insan nüfus hocam nüfus
diyeceksin nüfus coğrafyası bu bakın
bunlar zaten Türkçe çok fazla
ezberleyecek bir şey yok bunlarda sadece
mantığını öğren nüfus coğrafyası nüfusun
dağılışını nüfusu inceliyor yerleşme
coğrafyası diye bir konumuz var o da
yine ikinci dönem konularımız danan
oradan öğreneceğiz oraya gittiğimizde de
konut tiplerine bakacağız işte Niye
ahşaptan yapılmış bir yerde taştan
yapılmış ve yerleşmeyi etkileyen
faktörleri öğreneceğiz ya bu adamlar
niye buraya yerleşmiş ya burası dağlık
engebeli buraya yerleşmemiş Ha demek ki
burası dağlık engebeli olduğ olduğu için
düz yerlerde daha çok yerleşiyorlar
burada etkiliyor olan faktörler ne
yerleşme coğrafyasında bunu inceliyoruz
yararlandığı kısımlara bakın arkeoloji
Kazı bilmi arkeolojide kazı yaptığımızda
insanların geçmişte yerleştiği yerleri
öğreniyoruz değil mi Ondan
yararlanacağız E tabii tarihten
yararlanıyor Burası da tamam mı Tamam
sona doğru geliyoruz artık Şimdi burası
önemli ekonomi coğrafyası da beşeri
coğrafyanın altına giriyor mesela tarım
yapıyoruz enerji faaliyetlerinde
bulunuyoruz Sanayi yapıyoruz Bütün
bunların hepsi ekonomik bir faaliyet
değil mi hep hepsini ekonomi coğrafyası
altında görüyoruz bakın burada var maden
insan yapıyor Değil mi ulaşım insan
yapıyor tarım insan yapıyor enerji insan
yapıyor Sanayi Ticaret Turizm bakın
sağlık Bunların hepsi ekonomiyle alakalı
ve insan yapıyor bunların hepsini
ekonomi coğrafyasının altına koyuyoruz
unutma buradan neyden iktisattan
yararlanacağız geçelim siyasi coğrafyaya
gençler bakın bunları ezberlemenin gerek
yok Sizin Yani bunlar sana sorulduğunda
Sen ne olduğunu biliyorsan kendin
yerleştireceğiniz le beraber
yerleştirelim bana geldi dedi ki toprak
coğrafyası bunu beşeri coğrafyaya mı
koyarsın fiziki coğrafyaya mı E hocam
Toprak fiziki coğrafyaya koyacağım bu
kadar ezberleme bunları tamam mı Hangisi
neyin altında hangisinin inceleme alanı
ne ezberleme kendin öğrendin Şimdi
kendin yorumlayacak Tamam geldik siyasi
coğrafyaya E bu neyi inceleyecek e
siyasi olaylar var bunun coğrafi olan
mekansal ilişkileri nedenleri sonuçları
siyasi olayların neden ve sonuçlarına
bakacağız En çok da burada ülkelerin
jeopolitik konumunu inceliyoruz yani
Türkiye Asya ile Avrupa'nın ortasında Bu
bize nasıl bir bir güç sağlamış Siyasi
güç sağlamış gibi siyasi olayları
inceliyoruz uluslararası ilişkiler tarih
siyaset bunları da kullanabiliyoruz
Tamam geldi kültürel coğrafyaya bu
önemli bizim için aslında çünkü bununla
alakalı üniversite sınavında soru
sorabiliyor kültürlerin dağılışı yemek
müzik nasıl oluyor bu dinleri giyimleri
bunun coğrafya doğayla olan ilişkisi
giyimleri bile coğrafya değiştiriyor
demiştim sana bunu inceliyor işte neyden
yararlanıyor e kültür dedik sosyoloji
filoloji ilahiyat antropoloji bunları
diğer tarih dersinde de görüyorsunuz
durur hep fil Fi dediğimde mesela
kodlayayım size filoloji başka derste de
İşinize yarar filoloji diloloji bak
filoloji diloloji fil dil filoloji dil
bilmiy demiş Demek ki
antropolojiyi ben kodlayayım bu aynı
zamanda bizim antropojen Bozkır'da da
karşımıza çıkacak bunu
kodlayıp lazım yani antropoloji
dediğimizde aklımıza insan gelmeli insan
bilme ya Yani öyle bir şey kuracaksın ki
bağlantı antropoloji denildiğinde
antropoloji insan gelecek aklıma sen bir
kodla bakalım yorumlara yaz Eğer böyle
çok beğendiğim olursa sabitleyecek üstü
kültürel coğrafyayı da öğrendik mi Evet
hepsini öğrendik bir etkinlik yapacağız
şimdi bu etkinlikten sonraki video test
soru çözümü olacak o videoyu kaçırmıyor
tamam mı Bir de gençler şuraya sosyal
coğrafya da yazabilirsiniz tamam mı
kültürel coğrafya sosyal coğrafya da var
burada Onu da not alabilirsiniz gelelim
buradaki etkinliklerimizi yapalım şimdi
Aşağıda verilen araştırma konuların
coğraf hangi alt dallarına ait
olduklarını yazınız Yapı malzemelerinin
Kerpiç olduğu alanlarda depremin yıkıcı
etkisinin araştırılması Bak ne diyor
yapı malzemesi Kerpiç diyor E bu ne
yerleşme coğrafyası değil mi Şöyle
kalemimizi düzelteyim yerleşme mavi
alalım yerleşme bunu Bu arada benimle
beraber
doldurmuyorsa benimle beraber kontrol
ediyorsun Tamam bitki örtüsünün tarp
edildiği alanlarda erozyon heylam ve çığ
riskinin incelenmesi bak bitki örtüsünün
tahribinin etkisi e bitki örtüs tahrip
edilmesi Bitki coğrafyası değil mi bu
biyocoğrafya biyo canlılar coğrafyası
biyo coğrafya Antalya ve Muğla
yörelerinde bak akarsuların yeraltı
suları ve kaynakların araştırılması suyu
araştıracağız o zaman hidrografya hidro
hidrografya yazarken araları kesiyorum
zaman kaybetmeyelim diye diğeri Denizli
Aydın Manisa yörelerinde Jeotermal
santraller Jeotermal ne demek biliyor
musunuz şimdi öğren not al jeo yer jeo
yer jeo yer Ulan bak bir kere öğrendik
nasıl hep karşımıza çıkıyor Jeotermal
termak Termal terlemek termometre
sıcaklık Bunu ifade ediyor Jeotermal
kaynak Jeotermal su jeo yer sıcak yerin
altında gelen sıcak suları ifade etti
Bize Jeotermal su yerin altından sıcak
su geliyormuş ve bu santrallerde sıcak
suların çıktığı alanların incelenmesi bu
sıcak sulardan enerji elde ediliyor
gençler burada enerji elde ediliyor
enerji coğrafyası kalemimiz bozulmuş
Düzeltelim onu enerji coğrafyası buna
Bunun bir üst başlığı ekonomik coğrafya
diyebiliriz ekonomik coğrafya Tamam dii
Doğu Karadeniz'de hangi tür hayvanların
yetiştirildiği bak hayvan hem açık deniz
balık Balıkçılık Kültür balıkçılığı
hayvan Balıkçılık Bunlar tarım
coğrafyasına girer bunu unutma tamam mı
burada çok güzel bir not vereyim sana
tarım coğrafyası da hangisinin içindeydi
ekonomi ekonomik coğraf güzel bir not
vereyim sana tarım coğrafyasında sadece
tarımı incelemeye biz yani orada
tarımsal faaliyetleri değil sadece
pirinç nerede üretilir değil hayvancılık
da tarımın içine girer Balıkçılık da
tarımın içine girer ormancılık faaliyeti
de tarımın içine girer Bunların hepsi
tarımdır Bunu unutma notunu al önemli
bir bilgi bu geçtim Bulunduğunuz
yerleşmede ne kadar insan yaşadığının
tespit edilerek bunlarla doğal arşın ve
göçlerin etkisinin ne kadar olduğunun
tespit edilmesi ne kadar insan var nüfus
coğrafyası 7 Elazığ Artvin yörelerinde
maden yataklarının ve üretimlerinin
incelenmesi maden coğrafyası maden Evet
sıcaklık farklarının günlük Hayat
etkileri ve kış mevsiminde karın yerde
kalma süresinin araştırılması Neydi
klimatolojiye incelemiş bu madeni Neyin
içine koyacağız ekonomik coğrafyanın
içine koyuyorduk değil mi yaşanılan
bölgelerde internet yazılı ve görsel
medya hizmetleriyle bunların
kullanılabilirlik durumların
araştırılması gençler bakın çok güzel
bir kısma daha değinildi burada ulaşım
yazıyorum buna Yıldız alt ve notal tarım
için ne dedim sana çok istisna güzel bir
ayrıntıyı hayvancılık da tarıma girer
orman da tarıma girer Tamam Balıkçılık
da tarıma girer girer burada Bak ne
diyor yazılı görsel medya internet
ulaşımı sadece araç olarak
düşünmeyeceksin internet sosyal medya
Bunların hepsi ne ulaşım faaliyetidir O
yüzden bunları ulaşıma koyacaksın çok
güzel bir ayrıntı daha öğrendim burada
Akdeniz ve Karadeniz bölgelerindeki sı
dağlarda Ege Bölgesindeki sı dağların
kıyıya uzanışının ve bunların beşeri
faaliyetlere olan etkisinin
araştırılması Karadeniz bölgesindeki sı
dağlar dağlar yer şekilleri yer
şekillerini araştıracak neydi yer bilimi
diyecektim ya jeom morf F oloji Anlaştık
mı geçelim bu kısma gençler Bunu siz
çözüyorsunuz Çünkü bu ÖSYM çıkmış sorusu
bunu siz çözeceksiniz ben çözemiyorum
yasak olduğu için çözümünü aşağıya
yorumlar kısmına bekliyorum ben bunun
çözümünü yapamıyorum çözümünü yorumlara
belirt cevap ne örnek 4 soru cevap şu
diye yorumlara yaz Tamam geçelim son
etkinliğimize Bak ne diyor yer
şekillerinin engebeli olması nedeniyle
taraçalandırmak bahsediyor bak jeom
Morfoloji Çeltik ürünün yaygın olarak
yetiştirilmiş burada E ne Çeltik tarım
coğrafyası e tarım ekonomiye giriyordu
değil mi ekonomi yıllık sıcak
ortalamanın yüksek olması demiş e o
iklimle alakalı Klimatoloji
Klimatoloji bitki örtüsünün geniş
yapraklı olması Bitki coğrafyası yani
biyocoğrafya canlılar biyocoğrafya
toprakların omuz bakımından zengin tarım
yapmaya elverişli olması e topraktan
bahsediyor Toprak coğrafyası olacak
evler in araziye dağınık bir şekilde
yerleşmesi e bakın evlerin
yerleşmesinden bahsediyor Bu da yerleşme
coğrafyası olacak evet ikinci kısmı da
bitirmiş olduk coğrafyanın bölümlerini
Bu videoda bitirdik şimdi coğrafyanın
konusu ve bölümlerini iki videoya
bölmüştür ve şimdi bu videodan hemen
sonra coğrafyanın konusu ve bölümleri
ile alakalı test çözümleri gelecek test
çözümlerini izliyorsun konuyu iyice
pekiştiriyor musun bu videoyu da
bitirdik gençler videoları beğenin Çünkü
videoları beğendiğiniz de biz bunun bu
emeğimizin karşılığını alabiliyoruz
bakın renksiz Pardon renkli PDF
veriyoruz size bunca video üretiyoruz
size böyle güzel videolar üretiyoruz
Bunun karşılığını almamız için videoları
beğenmeniz gerekiyor Böylece bizim
videolarımız öne çıkıyor abone
oluyorsunuz durur Bu sayede de abone
olmanızı istiyoruz sizden bir sonraki
videoda test sorularını çözeceğiz iyice
konuyu pekiştirecek Ne diyorduk o zaman
Yunus hoca la bir defa öğren bir daha
asla unutma Test sorularında görüşmek
üzere